[Musique]
sur la photo là c'est moi je fais les
marchés
je suis une petite productrice
d'information j'essaye de vendre du bio
pour les canards certains pensent que ce
sont des salades d'autres des feuilles
de choux les médias les dégoûte
alors je les écoute je leur montre qu'on
peut faire des bonnes affaires
je leur explique qu'on peut trouver
l'élixir anti fake news j'ai trouvé du
poivre d'arvor cet été j'avais même des
benalla c'est-à-dire à 13h des fois on
débouche le jean pierre pernaut america
un jour il y en a un qui s'est approché
il m'a dit que ça valait pas un radis
mais tâchons alors il a peut-être raison
parce qu'en fait depuis plusieurs mois
je suis dans le flou j'ai vécu une
aventure éditoriale en début d'année qui
s'est bien planté un fiasco qui ont 11
mois a réduit à néant un rêve que
certains nourrissait depuis dix ans
alors j'y peux rien c'était un pari fou
créer un hebdomadaire papier 200 pages
sans publicité pour essayer de
réconcilier le grand public avec
l'information
le problème c'est que la violence de
cette aventure m'a ébranlé dans le plus
profond de mes convictions
cela ne fait qu'alimenter l'idée selon
laquelle on peut mettre tous les médias
dans le même sac
oui ma place aujourd'hui quelles valeurs
à l'information
dois je continuer à en produire
alors je vous rassure avec le temps
quand on se plante pas au pouce
j'ai été voir des confrères et des
concerts des consommateurs d'information
aussi en france et ailleurs j'ai mené
une petite enquête et je suis revenue
avec d'autres convictions
en fait pour moi bien s'informer c'est
comme bien manger il y en a qui font pas
gaffe ils s'en foutent ils ont peur de
manquer il souffre d'un faux bézy t on
stimule leur attention avec des
notifications des alertes des sweats
stories des choses sensationnelles
voilà ça y en a d'autres au contraire
c'est souvent les femmes elles souffrent
de médiane au rexy l'information c'est
le mal ça rend malade il faut se méfier
alors elles choisissent avec parcimonie
car on se met dans la tête mais je crois
que ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est la
crise de foi la crise de foie
en fait c'est même le trouble
informationnel le plus répandu
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus où est le
vrai où est le faux quelles sont nos
croyances et aujourd'hui c'est quoi une
société qui ne croient plus vous savez
une société de post vérité ou tout ce
qui ne nous plaît pas peut être qualifié
de fake news une société dans laquelle
la vérité de chacun se bâtit sur une
croyance qu'on a juste été vérifié en un
clic sur internet
en réalité aujourd'hui la surabondance
de news et d'information vous donne une
sensation de foisonnement mais cela ne
nous nourrit pas en france deux tiers de
l'information est une reprise un copier
coller de dépêches afp la gratuité créer
une diversité mais cela crée aussi du
vide et du faux en fait produite à la
va-vite d'information est une junkie
news vous savez on laval machinalement
aller fade et sans goût ou alors trop
sucrés ou trop gras ce pour être vrai et
le pire
c'est qu'on sait savez vous avez
l'impression d'être au courant mais on
n'est pas informé
et quand on s'informe on est mal informé
vous voyez le tableau
ah bon je devrais dire le même nature
morte parce que vu l'état du secteur
aujourd'hui c'est pas très glorieux
alors c'est la faute à qui tout ça je
vous le demande aux nouveaux chiens de
garde à ces journalistes qui sont à la
botte des actionnaires des industriels
des bolloré dry lagardère crétine ski
récemment c'est ça le racheter le monde
c'est eux c'est eux les fautifs qui qui
font partie des élites et qui côtoie ses
cercles mais je vous parle même pas de
google amazon facebook
whatsapp récemment au brésil 1e depuis
le plus jeune âge nous venons biberonne
à coups de clics d'algorithmes il nous
enferme dans un système et quand on est
journaliste on trinque
parce que ces réseaux sociaux capte les
revenus publicitaires
et en plus ils décident ou non de vous
faire parvenir notre information
n'importe qui aujourd'hui peut devenir
une micro célébrités un influenceur le
problème c'est qu'on baigne dans un bain
de commentaires de like de gifs animés
de vidéos de fées alternatif
le problème c'est qu'on est aussi comme
dans les rayons d'un grand supermarché
de l'information on est complètement
perdue lobotomisés zombifiés dit
certains alors si comme moi vous avez
envie de dire stop parce que moi j'ai
envie de dire stop
je vous propose quelque chose je vous
propose qu'on se penche sur la nature de
l'information sur la qualité de ce qu'on
utilise pour se vider la tête ou pire
pour cela remplir en fait sur la qualité
de l'information ça veut dire qu'on va
s'intéresser à la manière dont on va
penser cette information sur la manière
dont on peut la co créé ensemble mais
surtout la consommer en conscience je
suis persuadé qu'une bonne information
peut changer le monde et la mauvaise
information le change déjà aussi donc
pour cela je vais vous donner quelques
exemples
je vais vous parler des pesticides en
gironde d'où je viens
c'est le pire départements de france
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est martin
budo dans une enquête qui va réaliser
pour cacher investigations en février
2016 ce soir là vous étiez peut-être
comme moi devant la télévision
moi j'étais sur mon canapé j'avais aussi
mon ordinateur sur les sur les genoux et
j'avais entre les mains
le livre de l'enquète qui m'avait pas
fait parvenir en service de presse je
commence à regarder je suis sidéré on
apprend que des épandages de produits
phytosanitaires sont effectués à côté
des cours de récréation on a fait des
tests sur les cheveux des enfants des
échantillons ont été envoyés en fait on
a constaté qu'il y avait des résidus de
produits phytosanitaires
je feuillette le livre je me dépêche
d'aller jusqu'à la fin hélas je crains
le pire
je crains le pire parce que j'ai la
sensation que l'émission va se terminer
on va tous s'éteindre notre télé va
rester en colère impuissant sans doute
avec un grand malaise
et puis ça va s'arrêter là le lendemain
les politiques mondiales et de leur
déclaration les ong vont rappeler
qu'elles sont en train d'agir on va en
parler quelques jours et puis quoi
qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors là je me dépêche de pianoter sur
mon ordinateur un petit article c'est
pour mon blog pour le monde de
journalistes et donc jeunes intitulé que
faire après les révélations de cash
investigations sur les pesticides dedans
j'explique que d'autres enquêtes ont
déjà été faits des livres fabuleux qui
explique le problème des pesticides en
france et dans le monde
j'explique également que des ong et des
associations proposent au quotidien de
s'engager à leurs côtés pour essayer de
changer la donne je montre qu'on peut
s'alimenter différemment et agir au
quotidien aussi pour se passer de ces
produits phytosanitaires je me dépêche
d'envoyer l'article aux équipes du monde
il le met en une en quelques heures
cette élue 600 mille fois et partager 25
mille fois sur facebook c'est pas grand
chose mais c'est déjà beaucoup et ce
jour là j'ai l'impression d'avoir
poursuivi
l'investigation de cash investigations
mais surtout d'avoir fait mon boulot je
me sens alignés et cette approche c'est
celle qui m'anime c'est ce qui m'anime
chez public sénat c'est ce qui m'a animé
aussi au sein du un hebdo pendant 4
et en fait je me dis que c'est bien il
faut dire les choses mais vous plomber
vous laisser en plan ça ne me convient
pas j'ai envie aussi de montrer qu'il
existe des plans b je vais vous donner
un autre exemple
maintenant je vais vous parler du grand
méchant loup
et oui le grand méchant loup quand on en
parle dans les médias c'est souvent pour
vous dire qu'il est aux portes de paris
attention il ya plein de brebis qui ont
été tués pendant la nuit
et puis je crois même qu un imaginaire
un peu du chaperon rouge qui explique
que dans les maisons de retraite on
commence vraiment à s'inquiéter
voyez c'est un peu caricatural mais et
pour l'ours c'est pareil sauf que on
peut en parler autrement de cette
problématique
c'est ça qui est intéressant il ya
quelques années george monbiot qui est
un journaliste anglais pour le guardian
a fait un ted où il a parlé aussi de son
histoire
il a expliqué comment la réintroduction
du loup dans le parc de yellowstone aux
etats-unis a permis de rééquilibrer tout
le système
en fait au pas de yellowstone il avait
trop de serre les serres ça mange les
arbres et la végétation en introduisant
ce prédateur donc le loup il a mangé
quelques grands cervidés
du coup la végétation s'est mis a
repoussé qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
castors étaient contents ils ont pu
recommencer à faire des barrages dans
les rivières avec les barrages les
canards les poissons les amphibiens les
reptiliens ont pu venir se réintroduire
mais le loup est là aussi chasser
quelques coyotes du coup il est plus de
souris et de lapin ça fait le délice des
faucons des belettes et des renards et
les carcasses que le loup il est ce pas
finalement s'appeler aussi aux
charognards
petit à petit le parc de yellowstone a
retrouvé en fait un équilibre naturel
l'écosystème a retrouvé sa forme et le
loup a et est ici utile n'était plus vu
comme un grand prédateur dont il faut se
méfier je vais vous donner un autre
exemple sur le look beaucoup plus proche
de chez nous chez nice matin
ce matin on les appelle aussi souvent
nice menteur donc nice maintenant ils en
avaient ras-le-bol en fait parce qu'ils
sont dans le parc du mercantour
ils ont parc alpha avec plein de loups
tout ça mais ils sont rendu compte
qu'ils en avaient vraiment marre de
traiter sujet avec ces polémiques et ses
débats stériles
donc ils ont été passé la frontière ils
ont été en italie
en italie ils ont aussi des loups 1 il
n'y a pas les mêmes problèmes donc ils
sont dit mais que se passe-t-il donc ils
ont été faire un reportage sont venus
avec leurs portages et donc l'article
fait un petit cadrage pédagogique et
puis à côté ils expliquent ce qu'ils ont
observé là bas en italie les troupeaux
sont plus petits les éleveurs reste la
nuit avec leurs troupeaux on utilise des
lumières pour essayer d'effrayer les
loups et du coup il n'y a pas les mêmes
soucis quand ils ont mille articles en
ligne c'était aussi en 2016 c'était
l'article le plus lu d'année mais
vraiment sur les réseaux sociaux
également ça c'est énorme aimant
partager mais surtout la qualité des
commentaires en ligne avait rien à voir
on n'était plus dans ce débat stérile
on dit d'elle dans un échange fertile où
les gens pouvaient échanger sur des
solutions
les médias avaient montré qu'on pouvait
faire différemment et surtout qui
n'avaient pas de quoi crier au loup
donc en fait les exemples comme ça j'en
ai ramené à l'appel assis à table le
seattle times depuis quelques années à
monter l'éducation là pour essayer de
montrer qu'on peut s'appeler à la
question de l'éducation différemment
j'ai été à philadelphie
j'ai montré que 19 rédaction travaille
ensemble actuellement pour essayer de
parler de la pauvreté
autrement la bbc en angleterre s'est
attelée pendant un temps à parler
autrement des questions d'insertion ou
de pollution de l'air il ya énormément
de l'exemple comme ça qu'ils montrent
qu'aujourd'hui on peut envisager le
journalisme autrement alors là ce que je
vous dis ça compte surtout pour des pays
dans lesquels informer n'est pas un
délit je vous parle pas de pays où on
peut finir démembré dans un consulat
parce que ce qu'on dit ne plait pas vous
voyez de qui je parle
en fait plus que jamais aujourd'hui il
faut mettre la plume dans la plaie mais
il faut aussi que nous journalistes
parlions de celles et ceux qui la panse
avec un a
ça te plaît alors forcément parfois il
n'y a pas de solution parfois la
solution consiste à juste tuer le
problème mais parfois nous pouvons avec
rigueur essayez d'aller investiguer un
petit plus haut plus loin
essayer de remettre du liant dans la
société parce que les journalistes sont
un fil conducteur dans nos sociétés mais
c'est un fil conducteur qui a rouillé
il nous faut le réparer on attend plus
d'eux qu'ils fassent la pluie et le beau
temps
on ne va pas non plus attendre d'eux
qu'ils ne fassent que les arbitres du
réel affaires d un fox terrier et à les
traquer la fait que nous parce qu'en
fait ça on s'en fiche c'est important de
le dire une chose est fausse mais vos
croyances on va pas aller les contrées
on ne pourra rien faire contre ça mais
ils doivent retrouver une autre posture
et pour ça vous vous avez un rôle à
jouer
c'est comme pour l'alimentation
il faut regarder les étiquettes prenez
le temps de réfléchir
qu'est ce que vous lisez au quotidien
qu'est ce que vous regardez qu'est ce
que vous écoutez
savez-vous qui possèdent ces médias
savez vous quelles sont les intentions
derrière vous avez la sensation d'être
mal informé
mais pourquoi et comment pourriez-vous
faire pour être informé autrement et
surtout n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir
nous sommes à portée de clic
moi en un tweet ou un message facebook
je suis contactables est joignable très
aisée mais nous avons les outils à
disposition pour faire autrement
aujourd'hui
la bonne nouvelle c'est que comme pour
l'alimentation
on a des association de maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne vous savez si
systèmes qui permettent de consommer en
circuit court en mettant des
consommateurs et des producteurs
ensemble dans une association
c'est logique là il existe pareil pour
l'information
on pourrait appeler ça des associations
de maintien d'une presse indépendante
d'ailleurs alors mediapart
historiquement en france bien sûr mais
aussi les jours plus récemment reporter
ou d'autres structures qui font appel
aux grottes funding et qui permettent de
défendre une information indépendante de
qualité et avec cette confiance qui est
recréée vous pouvez aussi avoir le
pouvoir changer la donne alors
aujourd'hui le message que je veux vous
vous transmettre c'est que le
journaliste peut changer de posture
il doit éclairer l'avenir il doit
prendre la mesure de son impact
c'est à ce prix là qui pourra passer
d'un imaginaire de médias menteur et
trouver un rôle de médiateur cela est
cruciale pour la santé de nos sociétés
pour la survie de nos démocraties
c'est à cette condition là que nous
pouvons faire masse dans un esprit de
construction massif pour éclairer un
monde en prise avec la propagande mais
surtout passer de l'indignation à
l'action merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]